foreign
[Music]
Lord's podcast
welcome to the Lord's minute our quick
hit video series where we talk about all
the biggest happenings in gaming and
Beyond I'm your host Ty Swenson writer
for Lords of gaming and with me once
again is Lord King
we're back covering She-Hulk this time
our first ever superhuman case in the
new division head by Jennifer Walters
it's the people versus Emile Blonsky the
Abomination is trying to get on parole
and it's up to Jennifer Walters to
convince the people to let him out so
I'm gonna start with you Lord King how
are you feeling about seeing Emil
Blonsky back in The Fray Abomination
going a little bit more Zen and namaste
in his new uh line of Living Well what I
do like is that he's wearing some Crocs
right I know it when he carefully put
the Crocs down I'm like oh no the white
crap that was in episode three
but at episode two I noticed it right
off the rip I was like yo what blowski
has on Crocs and the fact that he had to
lay down his case to her that he was he
thought he was Captain America like a
lot of times
individuals you have to look at the
perspective of the villain right he
thought the Hulk was a raging Beast he
thought you know he was doing his uh his
duty uh to stop him to take him down you
know to to take down this this monster
but in in doing so he became a monster
itself and we all know that the super
soldier Serum is unstable in certain um
people like if their mental state isn't
uh all the way correct if their moral
compass isn't in the right direction
Allah uh us agent you know the the
previous Captain America who took over
you know for uh Steve Rogers uh during
that period of time during the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier
we know that it can have psychotic uh
episodes in these individuals now
coupled with that that the fact that
he's a raging gamma monster
that could have led some Credence to his
release so she she felt that she had a
good case but she was conflicted because
that's her cousin you know and he did
try to kill her cousin so his family
ties there I found it that just you know
a CEO her boss was like I don't care
about that you know you gotta defend him
you know type of thing either you know
take the case or you're not
now she wants to be taken serious as a
lawyer
as a as Jennifer Walters but she's
coming to grips that the world knows
that she's She-Hulk everyone knows this
is common knowledge and she thinks it's
like a circus but this is the only way
she's going to get a job and the media
uh how we can say uh uh Whirlwind that
surrounds her is is is is is the largest
that I've seen
since Miss Marvel I mean they've touched
on that social media aspect of it you
know in Miss Marvel how the world is
actively alive and it's happening in
real time and something that happens
right now is broadcast all over the
place I think she Hawks takes that a
step further where you have
um uh traditional uh linear television
also chiming in on it and then you have
the Cyber stuff that goes along with
that so when when we're coupling both
episodes here you know broadly yeah uh
when she's actually defending Blonsky in
the courtroom There's an actual media
circus that's going on and then in in
real time they're hearing things and
they're turning that speculation into
news like uh She-Hulk where you rejected
by The Avengers Rumor Has It She-Hulk
was effective it was rejected by yeah so
this stuff is real fun to watch the I
love the fact that she breaks the uh the
third wall I mean the fourth wall what I
did notice
when she has her hair back and maybe
it's a stature thing because of the hair
but I don't I don't believe so
I believe that she can control her
height and her size because when she was
walking in the office to her boss right
before Wong showed up she was at a
smaller stature compared to when she's
uh normally fully uh she-hulked out and
when she started to fight The Wrecking
Crew which
but I'm so disappointed in who they who
to actually look like right yeah yeah
um and and I guess if you're taking a
text from the comic books The Wrecking
Crew is a ragtag band of um of uh humans
that found the enchanted uh wrecking uh
uh crowbar and got imbued with the
powers because of Thor actually they're
actually because of Thor and actually
they did it kind of like the same thing
that CNA weapons and immediately I knew
exactly who they were yeah but they're
they're looked at as a joke and I
thought The Wrecking Crew was a little
bit more than a joke
um in the books one of my favorite uh
teams like I love Thunderball I love the
wrecker I love bulldoze I love that
stuff yeah it wasn't until they started
saying names in the car in the getaway
car that was like oh it was the record
then it was right but I I I I
automatically knew when I saw the ball
and chain when I saw the wrecking um
I want to know who their boss is but
when she turned into She-Hulk at that
moment
she was statuesque she was actually full
hulked out so
um I I believe that she can manipulate
uh her size in a form
for uh whatever like uh if she's doing
uh a deposition and stuff like that so
she does she can look less imposing I
think that's pretty cool as as well
that's an interesting thing I definitely
have to pay attention to that moving
forward wherever you watch just to
double check and catch that because I
definitely think the hair thing is one
piece of our character as well as as
she's trying to come to grips of being
She-Hulk and getting in front of this
you guys correct me if I'm wrong and and
traditionally in the comics um Jennifer
officer slash he-hulk
um
unlike
regular
um Bruce hulked out Rampage smashing she
relishes and and being a Hulk and being
um kind of more daring and just feeling
herself power
um and a couple with the fourth wall
breakers things like that but so far
with attorney at law she very much
prefers to be Jennifer Walter she
doesn't want to be in the spotlight she
wants to take up as less room as
possible
when she's hogged out and things like
that and she even says like she just
wants to get back to her old life and
when the case is concluded with Emil
Blonsky she was like hmm a power
dampener or something to remove my
Powers that's an idea yeah and what what
I noticed is they're mixing both books
so Savage She-Hulk is Jennifer Walters
just wanting to go back to her life
Sensational She-Hulk which is the books
that I freaking love to death because
John Byrne in the writing team that was
her leaning into the celebrity of it and
that's when I'm more more uh accustomed
to and that's what that's what I'm
seeing here that's when she's wearing
the tight fitting outfits she's wearing
the more
um seductive things her hair is more
voluptuous and I see them bouncing in
between the two and they're trying to
navigate it through I love the fact that
they bring it to an attention that this
show has cameos every episode and she
said you know I just want you to know
this who show this is and you know it
says She-Hulk I I love that I get that
from if you ever watched Invincible
every time they went to say invincible's
name like for the title
they would he would say you know hey man
aren't you in and before they could say
the name the logo of invincible pops up
so they're they're they're tearing from
all type of successful material and
they're uh piling on and and and making
a show that is constructed in a way that
it's really unpredictable I didn't
predict the elf that was a shape shifter
uh from Asgard but they're also keeping
it in the loop they're keeping
everything completely current and in
real time because the elf shapeshifter
tried to get up and tried to save Thor's
uh uh Mantra you know as God is not a
place as God as a people shut that down
real quick like we all recover that not
again and um yeah so to
um for for this case with versus Emile
Blonsky a couple things happened
Revelations for the audience one down
first now pretty much on her own for the
rest of the series her cousin Bruce
Banner is officially our planet
jettisoned on the spaceship off to take
care of the business that they
encountered with the spaceship in the
first episode
and with the Abomination back in the
picture and essentially a free man
um
it begs the question like who is going
to be the main antagonist that She-Hulk
is Ultimate gonna have to face take care
of with the Wrecking Crew we're still
not sure
who the boss is just that they wanted
Hulk blood slash she-hulk's blood
Abomination
um was uh we saw him in shanxi because
Wong needed a worthy opponent to justify
him becoming a supreme Master of the
Mystic Arts right and Emile Blonsky put
up a pretty good K slash front of like
hey I'm in full control now too I can
control when I go into the Abomination I
have my faculties but you know I'm a
pacifist now essentially you know
they've gone through this
um Reformation in prison I'm a nice guy
I have no interest in Revenge or
rampaging uh but then again like who's
to say what his real motives are uh so
I'm gonna bounce to you with the
Wrecking Crew abomination
the Tawny on the first episode who
ultimately is the overarching villain
that she looks either gonna discover or
have to come
um come to blows with well I believe
that they're gearing up for the
Thunderbolts everything is also going
into the West Coast Avengers so we do
see that everything is happening on the
west coast uh and that's going to lean
into what is going to turn into I um the
fact that uh Blonsky is very coherent
just like the She-Hulk and she's he's
able to control uh his
Transformations he's able to be
articulate in that same manner he's
controlled the Beast that's the same way
in the books he was always calculating
but his power levels base level he
doesn't get stronger as he gets angrier
like the Hulk he hasn't the Hulk has an
infinite infinite amount of uh power
given to him as he gets stronger as he
gets angrier but Blonsky doesn't he
starts off at a higher base level and he
stays at that same base level so
I believe that he's one of the manip
being manipulated by Madame Hydra to
form the Thunderbolts with Baron Zemo
and everybody else you need a Hulk but
I think that Hawk blood
is probably from the leader
oh because if Blonsky is from that world
the leader is from that world as well
and if that's Canon and we haven't seen
the leader since then and he's been
talked about then that means he is uh
active and in that world and maybe he
does need Hulk blood to manipulate it to
actually because remember he's the
leader is not a strong individual he's
mentally strong right so if he can get
some hog blood he can probably get to
the point where he's manufacturing Hawks
where you can get a bomb from Rick Jones
uh and you can get a red Hulk uh right
right you know and you can get the Red
She-Hulk from Betty Grant the
Abomination doesn't have the the
Catalyst that forced him to go after
Bruce which is the death of his wife and
his child that's not there right so when
you remove that from it from from being
Cannon
and his whole purpose was being
manipulated by the government the
Namaste stuff I don't believe that's an
act for him I believe that's a way out
and I believe he understands how to get
out of jail and he wants to do it the
proper way one thing also did you catch
this
when the news said
I heard that you were made from a failed
mob hit
that was the books because in the books
in Seahawk number one it was a failed
mob hit that actually got her to have
the blood transfusion by Bruce in order
to become the Savage She-Hulk and I said
this stuff is the gift that keeps on
giving right I love it the one thing
with the Namaste back to a meal that I
almost forgot is is watching the end
credits scene and the different images
a meal was on the parole bus heading
down he was waving by to his uh seven
soul mates wow so I don't think he's
settling down with the wives per se even
though that was a bit of the stretch
that he found his soul mates instead of
another women there that will
financially support him well eight eight
women but eight women yeah eight women
but remember as the condition of his
parole he has to go to the piece of land
right they're all going to meet him
there but they have to never support him
never Tran transforming into an
Abomination again right
um it's gonna be fun stuff to see I'm
I'm waiting for the Daredevil uh
when's that coming but uh one one more
thing to uh close out this segment uh
episode so far we've gotten um
we've gotten episodes from the MCU that
are getting
end credit scene She-Hulk has been a
series that has had one every single
time shout out to Megan the stallion and
so I'm curious on what's your take with
how she-hulks and crisis has have been
more more jokingly adding more depth
than getting to know She-Hulk a little
bit more uh with these after credit
scenes well I do like it may keeping the
tradition and they keep the they have
groomed the audience from the movies
don't get up you know just because the
the credits is rolling don't get up
there's going to be something next year
and you reward the audience for sitting
through the the credits and actually to
be honest with you the She-Hulk unlike
all other series actually the the end
credits is different every time as far
as
um the the you know Kevin feigen
everybody the artwork is different every
time and it's something to pay attention
to is you know they're giving you
they're giving you books
they're giving you uh the the video from
the actual show show it goes from show
an intro recap
intro title screen
show
outro cartoons and then end credit scene
which is actually fun I thought the
dancing and it's working with Megan the
stallions yeah yeah
once our blood got going she's like I'll
kill for you I'm like whoa
stuff that was good yeah I agree too
it's it's fun and
um you know it's a nice fit for She-Hulk
in my opinion and I I'm loving the
Direction shows going so far I enjoy the
tone
um the the subtle meaning slash things
that happen in society or social media
that they are directly addressing with
the path of Jennifer Walters and how
she's walking uh so I'm looking forward
to it again I'm excited for Daredevil I
know Jennifer said not every episode's
gonna be a cameo but if he pops up next
episode I'm not gonna say no to that it
looks like it and I have no problem with
it I love The Wrecking Crew
um I just wish it would have uh been the
guys that I wanted but yeah I I
understand what the MCU is doing and
they're grounded in this nature uh maybe
they do get as guardian Powers maybe
they do actually you know bulk up and do
become a credible threat because in
secret Wars it was The Wrecking Crew
along with Titania that actually beat
her you know down and broke a leg so
um I don't know do we do we get to that
that point do we get to that space But
bigger thing does she play a huge role
in secret Wars like she did in the books
we have this new character and I think
the sky is the limit especially the fact
that when she was getting mugged she was
like oh no I'm getting my like wait a
second I'm not kidding Mark I'm She-Hulk
that's right so I I I'm I'm so excited
for what's was to happen and I really
can't predict what the next episode is
going to be so this is the most fun you
know be a part of yep yep
excited to see what comes next but this
has been the Lord's minute we're here
every Monday Wednesday and Friday so
thank you so much for always being here
and joining us I'm ty Swenson here with
Lord King and this has been
the Lord's minute peace
[Music]